extremwetterereignisse nehmen zu und
lassen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler weltweit alarm schlagen
die fachleute haben eine schockierende
erklärung für die dramatischen
hitzerekorde hurricanes und wassermassen
die rede ist von einer klima eskalation
verheerende jahrtausend ereignisse
könnten damit zur normalität werden auch
extreme kältewellen klicks umsatz im
future hier gibt es drei mal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
haben sie willkommen das ist wirklich
dramatisch die welt steht kopf
hitzerekorde verheerende waldbrände
wassermassen lassen ganze landstriche
untergehen tornados und hurrikans wüten
ganze städte stehen unter wasser fest
steht in den vergangenen wochen und
monaten hat das wetter weltweit verrückt
gespielt fachleute beobachten das mit
entsetzen und geben jetzt eine
alarmierende warnung heraus solche klima
eskalationen könnten sich in zukunft
häufen und ja sogar zur normalität
werden und auch europa und eben auch
deutschland werden dabei wohl nicht
verschont bleiben alle spannenden effekt
zu diesem thema jetzt bei kids zum
science in future jetzt haben es wurde
hoffentlich alle verstanden die rekord
wassermassen die anfang september in new
york heimgesucht haben waren so enorm
dass der us wetterdienst sogar neue
farben für diese extremwert den seinen
grafiken erfinden musste der
bürgermeister von new york warnte davor
dass wir nun dauerhaft mit solchen
unwettern rechnen und leben müssten
zitat wir sind in einer ganz neuen welt
us präsident joe biden nannte den
hurrikan ida den fünf stärksten hurrikan
seit beginn der aufzeichnung seine
überreste hatten new york überflutet und
noch fünf tage später waren viele
haushalte ohne strom nicht nur deswegen
wird die diesjährige hurrikansaison im
atlantik als besonders bezeichnet sie
war zudem extrem früh gestartet mit elsa
anfang juli das nationale hurrikan
zentrum bezeichnete die aktivität der
tropischen wirbelstürme im august als
zitat überdurchschnittlich hoch
insgesamt hatten sich die drei
hurricanes formiert von dem zwei
besonders stark waren normal ist das
nicht bislang hatte man im monat august
immer mal mit ein oder zwei
hans zu tun zudem kam normalerweise nur
alle ein bis zwei jahre ein besonders
starker hurrikan dazu us präsident joe
biden sprach eine deutliche warnung aus
das land und die welt sind in gefahr das
ist keine übertreibung das ist eine
tatsache der klimawandel ist eine
existenzielle bedrohung für unser leben
für unsere wirtschaft und die bedrohung
ist hier es geht um leben und tod und
wir sitzen alle im selben boot wir
müssen handeln die rasant
fortschreitende veränderung des klimas
bezeichnet er als alarmstufe rot er geht
davon aus dass wir nun eine art
wendepunkt erreicht haben nun müsse man
handeln oder aber die ganze welt geraten
in große schwierigkeiten
unsere kinder werden in echten
schwierigkeiten stecken dass der
klimawandel naturkatastrophen weiter
verstärkt davor warnen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
schon lange doch eine neue studie der
weltwetterorganisation
wmo liegt jetzt neue zahlen und fakten
auf den tisch demnach ist die zahl der
wetter und klima bedingten katastrophen
seit dem jahr 1970 deutlich gestiegen
zwischen 2000 und 2009 waren es sogar
fünf mal so viele wie in den siebziger
jahren warnt die weltwetterorganisation
in einem neuen bericht überschwemmungen
und stürme bilden fast 80 prozent dieser
katastrophen ereignisse und solche
naturkatastrophen kosten nicht nur viel
geld sondern auch unzählige
menschenleben der hurrikan ida könnte
mit zu den teuersten katastrophen
überhaupt werden den rekord hält bislang
hurrikan katrina der vor 16 jahren 2005
new orleans und die umliegende region
verwüstet hatte schäden von knapp 140
milliarden euro wurden verursacht noch
viel schlimmer dass solche katastrophen
auch menschenleben kosten und zwar nicht
nur weit entfernt in den usa sondern
auch direkt bei uns mitten in
deutschland das hochwasser im juli
diesen jahres in rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen forderte 180
todesopfer insgesamt gab es 11.000
katastrophen zwischen 1970 und 2019 und
insgesamt zwei millionen menschen die
dadurch ums leben kamen pro jahr 10
stieg die zahl der wetterbedingten
katastrophen von 711 von 1970 bis 1979
auf
3535 von 2000 bis 2009 wie ist die
aktuelle studie der dabei offenbart bei
ihrer analyse werteten die forschenden
daten zu dürren stürme überschwemmungen
und extremen hitze ereignissen und
waldbränden aus und klar ist solche
katastrophen werden nicht nur häufiger
sondern auch intensiver und das bedingt
durch den menschengemachten klimawandel
battery talas der generalsekretär der
dbu sagt dazu das bedeutet mehr
hitzewellen dürren waldbrände wie wir
sie jüngst in europa und nordamerika
gesehen haben der amerikanische sommer
hatte in diesem jahr tatsächlich bereits
alarmierend begonnen in einigen teilen
im westen kanadas der usa wurden
wärmerekorde gebrochen unerträgliche
knapp 50 grad celsius zeigte das
thermometer an bereits zu diesem
zeitpunkt sprach die fachwelt eine
warnung aus demnach dürfte solch ein
ereignis zumindest rechnerisch gesehen
in nur einem von
8000 jahren vorkommen hat der
klimawandel möglicherweise eine schwelle
erreicht bei der sich wetterextremen
plötzlich sprunghaft häufen demnach
könnte es zu einer klima eskalation
kommen ja tausende ereignisse würden
dann zur normalität der klima- forscher
anders levermann vom potsdam institut
für klimafolgenforschung zählt die
folgen auf mit denen wir uns bereits
jetzt und in naher zukunft wohl
arrangieren müssen durch den klimawandel
werden in vielen teilen der erde
trockene orte trockener und nasser
region nasa doch wie ist beispielsweise
das unwetter in new york genau zustande
gekommen laut den fachleuten kamen hier
mehrere faktoren zusammen dazu levermann
mit einer erklärung hurricanes und
taifune ziehen ihre energie aus der
oberflächentemperatur des ozeans durch
die globale erwärmung erhöhen wird diese
oberflächentemperatur und stellen damit
den hurricanes mehr energie zur
verfügung die folge davon wirbelstürme
werden stärker und nicht nur das starke
wirbelstürme passieren zudem häufiger in
einer anderen aktuellen studie konnte
ein internationales forschungsteam nun
auch endlich die frage klären wie die
heftige kältewelle anfang dieses jahres
in den usa zustande kommen konnte mehr
als 200 menschen starben und millionen
menschen hatten weder heizung noch
elektrizität auch dieses ereignis steht
in direktem zusammenhang mit dem
klimawandel wie die forschenden nun
offenbaren konnten demnach wird der
polarwirbel über nordamerika durch mehr
schnee in sibirien und einer geringeren
eisdecke im polarmeer langsamer
normalerweise sorgt diese win zone dafür
das kalte und warme luftmassen
voneinander getrennt werden und er
erzeugt einen starken jetstream nimmt
der polarwirbel und damit auch diese
luftströmung aber ab gelangen polare
luftströme tief nach süden in mittleren
breiten der jetstream bildet sogenannte
rossi wählen die dann bis weit nach
süden reichen und kalte luft in den
süden transportieren dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam für die menschengemachte
weltweite erwärmung wird vorausgesagt
dass sie einige wetter extreme
verstärken wird zum beispiel mehr
hitzewellen und starke niederschläge
nicht aber heftiges winterwetter wird
kaltlufteinbrüche und starke schneefälle
die aktuelle studie zeigt nun also zum
ersten mal dass die erderwärmung in den
usa auch für extrem kälte sorgen kann
sind die aktuellen ereignisse in den usa
und also endlich der weckruf um den
kampf gegen die klimakrise schnell und
effektiv anzugehen zumindest gibt es nur
mit joe biden einen us präsidenten der
die klimapolitik ernsthaft verfolgen
will doch viel zeit bleibt nicht anfang
november wird die weltklimakonferenz in
glasgow stattfinden aber die zeichen
stehen nicht gut dass 2015 in paris
vereinbarte ziel zu erreichen demnach
wollte man die erderwärmung im vergleich
zur vorindustriellen zeit auf 1,5 grad
begrenzen greta team berg dazu es wird
so sein wie bei jeder anderen konferenz
auch wir ignorieren die klimakrise immer
noch und der klimawandel hat noch andere
folgen alarmierende warnung
menschengroße ratten als folge des
klimawandels anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann bleib dran